great to be drinking again I had to take
a break that's a nightmare not fun I had
to take a break because I went on
antibiotics I don't know if you've done
that but you find out how big of a booze
bag you really are when you have to go
on antibiotics my doctor said hey you
can't drink while you're on these
antibiotics and I said okay what makes
you think that I drink and he said well
I'm looking at your face your your big
dumb Irish head gives it away I said
okay fine he goes yeah you can't drink
for a week and I said okay yeah like a
um a workweek that'll do right that's
probably Monday Wednesday is that your
week that's my week to be honest with
you Thursday usually kicks off the
weekend so he goes you can't go a week
without drinking booze and I said I
don't think so I don't think so to be
honest with you now and he said that's
that's an issue we should give you a
physical so I had to I do a physical we
have to fill out a form have you ever
had to do this and that is a nightmare
on the first question it says how many
drinks do you have a week have you seen
this do you know you're laughing because
you know how many drinks you have a week
and the first answer is zero to one what
what kind of psychopath has one drink a
week
who is this person that I'm very afraid
of that just goes one that's it for me
for the week yeah one to start the week
yeah to begin it maybe that's so creepy
one is creepier than zero or a hundred
yeah by far because zero says hey man I
used to have a problem okay and a
hundred says hey man I currently have a
problem but one says I'm keeping a
secret and it's a problem I've changed
my life
recently for the better I started
sleeping naked and it's the greatest
thing I've ever done doing it
Bravo I feel so free I can swim around
and there are no restrictions now it's
interesting that socially we're told to
sleep in clothes isn't that weird like
we're like we're told that we should be
sleeping and clothes at night for some
reason I remember being 8 years old
dancing on my bed nude as you do when
you're 8 years old my mother came in and
she said Andrew put on some clothes and
get to bed now
I said why and she said we don't sleep
naked in this house and I said why not
and she said what if in the middle of
the night the house what catches on fire
why does everybody know that we all know
that who spread that around to the world
in what era of time were so many homes
just setting ablaze in the middle of the
night with naked people outside like oh
now
everybody also I'm 8 years old is that
what I need to hear before I rest my
little head forget about the monsters
this thing is gonna set on fire at
midnight you're fine
it's crazy cuz now I'm a grown-up I
sleep naked I think what if the house
catches on fire who cares what's gonna
happen you guys I'm gonna be outside
naked yeah right right yeah that's it
that's it what kind of [ __ ] of a
neighbor would I have to have who would
make fun of my penis
well my house is on fire I just got back
from Montreal beautiful city I don't
know if you've been there but they speak
they speak France there and I don't
speak friends and I was wandering the
streets kind of lonely I was looking for
a companion and I looked in this window
and there was a phone number and below
what it said a lover and I thought a
thank you but I don't speak France and
it actually said alo you er Loa which
means for rent okay yeah so I had a
totally different conversation that I
thought I was gonna have I called this
woman who picked up she goes Bonjour and
I said yeah the lover and she goes yeah
oh okay yeah American umm yeah okay so
it is 1,500 and I said okay that's
expensive
and then she said um and I must meet you
first and I said that's not how this
goes I've done this before
we're both rolling the dice here lady
okay and then she said I must remind you
um no pets and I said lady for $1,500
I'm bringing a pet
[Applause]
you